♪ ♪
>> Dana: ILHAN OMAR FACING
BACKLASH FOR COMMENTS ABOUT THE
CHAOS IN VENEZUELA.
THE FRESHMAN DEMOCRAT SUGGESTING
AMERICA COULD BE PARTLY TO BLAME
FOR THE UPRISING AGAINST NICOLAS
MADURO SOCIALIST REGIME.
>> A LOT OF THE POLICIES WE'VE
PUT IN PLACE HAS KIND OF HELPED
LEAD THE DEVASTATION IN
VENEZUELA.
THIS PARTICULAR BULLYING ON THE
USE OF SANCTIONS TO EVENTUALLY
INTERVENE AND MAKE REGIME CHANGE
REALLY DOES NOT HELP THE PEOPLE
OF COUNTRIES LIKE VENEZUELA.
>> Dana: TO BE FAIR, SHE GAVE
ANOTHER STATEMENT TO FOX TODAY
AND I THINK WE SHOULD PLAY THIS
BECAUSE SHE WAS TRYING TO
EXPLAIN MORE ABOUT WHAT SHE
THINKS.
WATCH.
>> THE UNITED STATES' ROLE
SHOULD BE ONE THAT IS EXECUTING
FOR THERE TO BE FAIR ELECTIONS.
IT SHOULD BE ONE OF GUIDANCE AND
TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE PUSHING
FOR REGIME CHANGE OR IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF VENEZUELA AND THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Dana: JESSE, NOT IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE VENEZUELAN
PEOPLE TO HAVE REGIME CHANGE.
>> Jesse: WOW.
I WANT HER TO SAY ONE GOOD THING
ABOUT AMERICA, JUST ONE.
I WOULD ISSUE A CHALLENGE.
OMAR, PLEASE SAY ONE GOOD THING
ABOUT AMERICA.
A >> Greg: AT LEAST ABOUT
JESSE.
>> Jesse: WE HEAR HER SAY
WHAT'S WRONG WITH AMERICA.
JUST SAY WHAT YOU'RE PROUD OF.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE
COUNTERBALANCE THEM OF THE
NEGATIVITY THAT YOU HEAR COMING
OUT OF HER MOUTH.
ALSO WE SHOULD SEND HER
DICTIONARY BECAUSE AMERICA IS
NOT BULLYING THE PEOPLE OF
VENEZUELA.
IT IS MADURO AND THE
RUSSIAN-BACKED MILITARY THAT ARE
TAKING AWAY PEOPLE'S RIGHTS AND
SHOOTING INTO THE CROWD AND
DOING ALL THOSE THINGS.
ALSO THIS IS WHAT SOCIALISTS DO.
WHEN SOMETHING GOOD HAPPENS IN
THE WORLD WHAT THEY DO IS THEY
SAY WHY CAN AMERICA BE LIKE THAT
COUNTRY?
AND THEN WHEN SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENS IN THE WORLD, THEY SAY
THAT'S AMERICA'S FAULT THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING.
THEY CAN NEVER SEE THE POINT
THAT SOCIALISM IS FAILING ON ITS
OWN.
REMEMBER WHAT THE COMMUNISTS DID
AFTER THE SOVIET UNION
COLLAPSED.
COMMUNISM HAS NEVER BEEN
PERFECTLY IMPLEMENTED.
THEY SAID THE SAME THING WITH
OBAMACARE.
OBAMACARE FAILED BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP UNDERMINED IT.
AT THIS POINT I WANT HER TO DO
THIS.
STOP SIDING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
YOU SAY YOU WANT TO START WORLD
WAR III OVER RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE WITH THE ELECTION
NOW THEY ARE INTERFERING
PHYSICALLY IN OUR HEMISPHERE IN
-- AND YOU ARE SIDING WITH THEM.
>> Dana: THE CONSTITUTION IN
VENEZUELA WAS FOLLOWED AND THEY
RECOGNIZED PRESIDENT, GUAIDO,
THEY ARE FOLLOWING.
MADURO IS NOT THE RECOGNIZED
LEADER OF THE COUNTRY ANYMORE.
>> Jedediah: SHE IS SAYING
THAT OUR ROLE WOULD BE
ADVOCATING FOR FAIR ELECTIONS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DID.
SHE USES THE WORD BULLYING.
IF WE WERE BULLYING, YOUR
BULLYING A GUY WHOSE MILITARY
TANKS ARE MOWING DOWN PEOPLE IN
THE STREETS.
>> Jesse: YOUR BULLYING THE
BULLY.
>> Jedediah: SOMEONE HAS TO
STAND UP FOR THESE PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMPLETELY
UNARMED, THEY FEEL EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE.
THEY ARE STARVING THE STREETS.
THEY ARE DIGGING THROUGH GARBAGE
FOR FOOD.
I COMMEND ANY COUNTRY IN ANY
LEADER OF ANY COUNTRY WHO
BULLIES A LEADER WHO SUBJECTS
PEOPLE TO THAT ATROCITY.
>> Dana: SOME PEOPLE MIGHT SAY
WE ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH TO HELP
THEM.
>> Greg: SOME PEOPLE MIGHT BE
MEAN.
SHE POSITIONS HERSELF WHO AS
SOMEONE WHO IS FOR THE UNDERDOG
SO SHE SHOULD BE OUT FRONT FOR
THESE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE THE TRUE OPPRESSED.
THE THING IS HER IDEOLOGY EXISTS
INDEPENDENT OF POLITICS OR
RELIGION.
IT'S INGRAINED IN THE HARD LEFT
OF THE OPPRESSOR VERSUS
OPPRESSED IDEOLOGY.
SHE BELIEVES PLACES LIKE AMERICA
ARE GUILTY OF IMPERIALISM, BEING
THE OPPRESSOR.
HERE'S A SITUATION WHERE YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE BEING
DEPRESSED BUT ALL SHE SEES IS
THE YANKEE IMPERIALISM THAT IS
INGRAINED NOT FROM ANY RELIGION.
NOT ALSO REALLY FROM POLITICS
BUT FROM OUR OWN ACADEMIA.
THIS ISN'T MOHAMMED'S DOCTRINE.
THE RADICAL BELIEF THAT IF YOU
WILL GET ANY EVIL AROUND THE
WORLD, AMERICA IS AT THE ROOTS.
>> Dana: SHE MIGHT SAY IT'S
BASED ON HER EXPERIENCE AS A
CHILD IN A REFUGEE CAMP AND THEN
SHE CAME TO AMERICA AND SHE HAD
A DIFFERENT UPBRINGING.
SHE WAS VERY FRUSTRATED THAT THE
UNITED STATES -- SHE DIDN'T
THINK WAS HELPING THEM ENOUGH.
>> Juan: THAT'S AN ACCURATE
ACCOUNT BUT I THINK SHE'S WRONG
ON THIS POINT.
TO ME, THE UNITED STATES HAS A
HISTORY OF BULLYING,
INTERFERENCE AND LATIN AMERICA.
NICARAGUA, EL SALVADOR AND THE
KIND OF UNREST THAT WE FOMENTED
THEIR QUITE INTENTIONALLY.
THE CIA WAS VERY ACTIVE.
I THINK IN THIS CASE, WHAT YOU
HAVE IS NOT SO MUCH SOCIALISM,
JESSE, AS DESPERATE.
YOU THINK OF HUGO CHAVEZ,
NICOLAS MADURO OR YOU THINK OF
THE INFLUENCE COMING FROM PUTIN,
COMING FROM THE CHINESE AS WELL.
THESE ARE DESPERATE WHO
TRYING -- DESPOTS TRYING TO RUN
OVER DESERVING PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: IT DOESN'T MEAN THEY
CAN'T BE --
>> Juan: IT'S SEPARATE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
SOCIALIST RULE.
THESE ARE CRUEL, INDIFFERENT
LEADERS.
>> Jesse: HOW DID THEY GET
THERE?
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT BIG OIL COMPANIES MAKING
DEALS, RUNNING OVER PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: BIG OIL COMPANIES
DID NOT RUN THIS COUNTRY INTO
THE GROUND.
>> Juan: YOU SHOULD DO SOME
STUDYING BECAUSE --
>> Jesse: I HAVE.
THEY NATIONALIZE THE OIL
COMPANIES.
>> Juan: IN RESPONSE TO THE
ABUSES OF BIG OIL.
I DON'T TICKETS WORTH GOING OVER
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SAY THAT SHE'S WRONG AND THAT
THE REASON FOR THIS COLLAPSE IS
DESPOTIC BEHAVIOR THAT NEEDS TO
BE COUNTERED INSTEAD OF
SUPPORTED BY THE RUSSIANS ON THE
CHINESE.
>> Greg: SHE HAS BEEN WRONG ON
EVERYTHING.
THE POINT IS THE ADVICE TO
REPUBLICANS ABOUT OMAR IS THE
SAME ADVICE I GIVE TO DEMOCRATS
ABOUT TRUMP.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH HER,
TRY TO WIN THE ELECTION.